what could be a challenging start to the
holiday travel season snow made roads
slick Friday and made any thought of
getting out a ton of slow one along
Interstate 25 in Castle Rock Colorado at
south of Denver it's one of several
storms threatening to hamper the near
record number of Americans getting a
jump on their travel plans this
Thanksgiving weekend according to
triple-a 55 million people will be
traveling more than 50 miles this week
that includes more than 49 million on
the roads that's in addition to the
nearly four and a half million traveling
by air so what is in store for all of
them meteorologist Jeff beard Ellie is
here with the forecast Jeff good morning
good morning Jeff please do not shoot
the messenger that's all I ask
it's gonna be a very active week but
it's starting out eerily quiet across
the United States we have this little
storm which is going to become a bigger
storm later today and tonight and this
probably will eventually start causing
some flight delays especially tonight
into tomorrow it's mostly a rain event
and that is the good news as the system
moves into the Northeast little nuisance
snow here in the Ohio Valley bigger
snowstorm for northern New England but
New York City Boston this is an all rain
event and that should help probably keep
the travel delays down just a bit
the big story next week huge dip in the
jet stream in the West it's mild and
quiet in the southeast so that's nice
but look at this storm that develops on
Tuesday Denver six to 12 inches of snow
that tracks right toward Chicago right
now Chicago's probably in the rain and
not the snow that will help but watch
out for travel delays Green Bay Chicago
look at that wind crank up Wednesday
Wednesday night and Thursday across the
Great Lakes and Northeast that is likely
to cause some flight delays and watch
out the balloons may not actually
unfortunately be part of the parade on
Thanksgiving morning because the wind
gusts could be 40 miles an hour we'll
watch that closely there's that dip in
the jet another big storms slamming into
the West Coast Wednesday Thursday and
Friday that means my advice take the
skis out and go skiing
nice fresh powder across the West
alright Jeff thank you we'll keep
watching